permanent all-wheel drive
electromechanical power steering and a
multi-link sports suspension with
adjustable dampers howdy
has packed a lot of technology into this
little pocket rocket that's shaking up
the compact class our tester montes
corrode says this Audi a1 really isn't
an a1 at all it's the most powerful
variant in the model line the s-1 the
carp has a 231 horsepower engine and
permanent Quattro all-wheel drive and
today Montes plans to see if it can live
up to expectations
like a reptile the s-1 sits low to the
ground but it doesn't need to bask in
the Sun it generates enough heat on its
own the hot hatches suspension has been
lowered by 10 millimeters compared to
standard a1 models the s1 also boasts
brakes that can stop on a dime and the
Audi flaunts its flagship model status
with a showy rear spoiler
and twin oval tailpipes with chrome tips
it's paint job is flashy - there's no
doubt this cars meant to stand out from
the crowd the s-1 Sportback gets its
incredible power from its turbocharged
2-liter TFSI engine which produces up to
370 Newton meters of torque it sound as
sporty and sonorous the four-door hot
hatch can go from 0 to 100 kilometers an
hour in just 5.9 seconds and reach a top
speed of 250 kilometers an hour on
average the car is a fuel mileage of 7.1
litres per 100 kilometers
montes says it takes a little while for
the turbo to kick in but when it does
the car goes like lightning hitting you
to your seat and thanks to the Quattro
all-wheel drive there's no need to worry
about losing traction as the car really
grips the road Montes says the all-wheel
drive has another advantage too when
picking up speed the motor has less
effect on the steering for instance when
accelerating out of a curve Montes finds
the interior to be of high quality as
you'd expect in an Audi there's a fine
mix of materials and little details like
the red rings around the air vent and
the start/stop button and some of the S
ones details hinted outies motorsport
pedigree like the stainless steel pedal
caps and the leather trim flat-bottom
steering wheel the s1 is fitted with a
6-speed manual transmission and there's
no overlooking the fact that this cars a
Quattro
sport seats with integrated headrests
kakuhen the driver and front seat
passenger giving them the feeling of
being in a real race car but open the
trunk and you'll see that there's not
much luggage space it's one of the s
ones minor weaknesses
so what's mattis's overall impression he
says the s1 is great fun to drive it
doesn't have a big trunk or a lot of
room in the backseat but he says these
aren't must-haves for a fun hot hatch
but that fun does come at a price in
Germany the s-1 has a starting price of
close to thirty one thousand euros
thirteen thousand more than a bare-bones
a1 sportback